welcome no oh my god sorry
good morning millennials i'm so sorry
i've been doing the show by myself for
five days and i'm short-circuiting good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy friday as rebecca
back would say hope everyone had a great
week i'm so excited for today's show
because we are joined by someone who's
been on my mind for the last week
because i have been reading his memoir
non-stop and it is really been a
life-changing week for me and i'm so do
you feel weird sitting here like knowing
how much i know about you i no i i
prefer it yeah no okay i definitely want
to eye not to make everything about me
please but when i was doing podcasts
like for my book i felt weird because i
was like really personal in the book and
you went like above and beyond sure so
now you're doing interviews of course
not everyone reads the book and i've
been watching some of your podcasts
knowing some people didn't read the book
yes um
and it feels like uncomfortable because
it's like a diary almost like you really
go hard in this book i didn't feel that
raw and transparent when i was writing
it but since i've sort of put it out
into the world i was like oh god yeah it
feels naked
it's very exposing and you know i feel
like a lot of toasters can probably
relate to this like people who grew up
with you and then
in different iterations of our life like
you've always been woven in and out of
our lives like in the vine area you were
like a huge part of our lives for those
of us who were invested in popular
culture which if you're listening to
this podcast you obviously were come on
um and now with like all these tv shows
and i just i loved the book so much and
we're gonna do a whole segment on it you
are gonna host with me we're gonna get
your your take on what's going on in the
world but i just have to congratulate
you like i loved it so much and it was
long not page wise but your font was
kind of small so like i feel like your
book actually could have been double the
amount of pages if your font was bigger
is that better if it was like the size
of a harry potter book well so the thing
is like i have this thing like i can't
watch long movies and i can't read long
books like i just i have no patience for
it but i enjoyed your book so much even
though i thought it was kind of long
i'm honored i you know i know you are
randy reader over there i always see you
on your ig stories you've got your
kindle on vacation who reads on vacation
that's like the only place to read i
guess yeah where else if you're gonna
read you know
if you had to read a book what are you
gonna do read it when you're like
babysitting your son or when you're on
the beach it's true that's probably like
the the proper environment you know i'm
like a man of the people i think people
are reading on the train and whatnot oh
i guess yes yes i don't um have a
commute because i live right here so i
guess that's fair um are you a big pop
culture girly yeah i think so yeah i
like the things and i'm married to a
secret pop culture lover my wife tries
to front like she's above it she loves
the housewives she loves her things do
you pretend to hate it and then like
watch over her shoulder no i'm down the
clown i there was a time like in
2017-2018 where we had our shots of
sunset vanderpump rules like jersey
shore
and it just felt like it really bonded
us as a couple it was the golden era of
reality television the jersey shore
years more specifically you know i'm
friends with kirsten dodie from oh my
god you are yeah who am i i literally
love her she's as good as it gets she's
a unique individual isn't it just odd
when you're around these people that
you've watched and it's odd to like talk
about them and then like see them in
social settings it's like awkward yeah
it's and and also i'm like do i
like what do i bring up to you do i
bring up this show like you don't want
to be a fan but like you are
it's so i i remember when i met like
because i'm a die-hard howard stern fan
forever
and you don't know what schtick and
what's and i i think i've told this
story before so when i was doing that
show graham fathered with john stamos
and i played his son and i wish i could
teleport and tell chubby 13 year old
josh that one day you would be like a
kin to josh neymar chanted it would have
made my bar mitch for way better that
could have been your theme yeah what was
your bar mitzvah theme yeah rough it was
broadway
[Laughter]
broadway by the way that was my mom my
mom forced that on me okay so we like a
years ago we did a whole patreon episode
podcast about like batman's videos and
jewish culture and i have like trauma
with my mom it's the theme because i had
absolutely no choice like it was just
chosen for me by like the planner and
all the adults involved my mom was very
into it and i like was like i had so
much shame associated with like i didn't
want to tell you what it was come on
because for those who have never been or
experienced environments they're like
speech themes need to be very specific
you are great broadway is extremely
specific most kids the most popular ones
are like you know josh's candy bar or uh
you know baseball like something the kid
loves
and so mine i like don't even want to
say it like but you can find out now at
the 10 level of patreon actually it's
7.99
um mine was um
colors
which is just like vague i guess i
didn't realize at the time like it was
like rainbow themed which i guess just
meant i was like an ally in training
because i didn't really do it on purpose
and now i look back thinking it was very
kismet since i consider myself a great
ally of the lgbtq plus community yes but
like it was it was like color me claudia
which like just isn't a theme
that's just such a
like 50s party planning
like jewish she lives on long island
she's like i know what she'll love
college
like
just not a lot of thought there did you
get bullied a lot in school i did for
your weight yeah oh yeah but not for
loving broadway and being an actor
i mean the actor thing was kind of like
the broadway thing was sort of pushed on
because my mom was like such a musical
theater person and i was like sitcoms
like family matters full house and you
know adam sandler movies so
the acting thing was kind of cool yeah
um that you know they were like oh we
saw you in a toy commercial right
but but for being overweight yeah i mean
it was instant i mean it was almost like
i would notice people would have like a
knee-jerk reaction like i would see
something flash in their eyes and be
like here it comes yeah like they could
almost couldn't hold themselves back
right right right i think people
tell me what you think i think people
have this like subconscious weird thing
of like maybe if i shame him he'll do
something about it i think when it comes
to kids
and you talked a lot in the book about
how like at a very young age you were
like 290 pounds yeah and i think when it
comes to kids adults are so nasty but
they really come at it with good
intentions like thinking they're being
helpful like maybe he doesn't know he's
bad
but like you obviously do uh yeah i'm
i'm in a dog section of macy's it's
called huskies okay
i can't get away from it but i do have
to say i think you wrote about the fat
experience like
perfectly like because unless you've
really experienced it like you'll never
forget the first time you heard someone
call you fat whether or not they meant
for you to hear it or not like i thought
the way you wrote about it was so
poignant and someone who's experienced
it like i just loved it because you put
it into words better than anyone ever
could i so appreciate that and i was
really careful and i made sure to like
my wife was so helpful with that section
because she just was like you have to
walk this fine line because things are
better today yeah and they should be i
yes well you know i mean okay we're
gonna dive in but i had one question
that i want to ask you which now seems
like a good time to bring it up when you
talked about your weight loss and i was
really interested to open the book and
find the magic secret to losing weight
and there wasn't one it was just hard
work which was really disappointing i
know it's really upsetting incredibly
upsetting don't buy the book it's
useless
but i found in the chapters where you
were talking about like your decision to
lose weight i felt like you were
defending that choice a lot because we
like like in some way i think you felt
writing about wanting to lose weight
whether it was for your mental health or
your physical health was like offensive
to some people and you were kind of
defending that against the body
positivity movement like you can't be
body positive if you want to lose weight
right
did you do that intentionally well i
just think i was walking these i'm just
so naturally i'm constantly taking the
piss out of myself it's just always been
my defense mechanism like i'll make fun
of myself first of course and and it
also was
you know it became this thing where it
it felt so damn public that if i didn't
lean into it it would look like i was
avoiding it and scared of it yeah so i
wanted to make sure that i'm i truly am
at 35 at least as much as i think over
it in a good way good good i mean i've
been the sweet since i was 19. right it
sticks with you even if it doesn't
physically stick with you totally but i
did want to honor that thing which was
like body positivity all these things
that have happened over the last 20
years is so good and right and i do want
to honor that because like i talk about
growing up you tell me i would see other
boys who were like 12 13 and were
overweight they'd whip their shirt off
yes
cannonball live freely and i'd be like
that's superhero yeah i completely agree
like how are you not worried right how
are you not self-conscious and i'm like
in a thermal and a t-shirt
like you know waddling in the three-foot
section so i i wanted to make sure that
i like i wanted to talk honestly about
my experience while also like
not being totally a jerk to myself
because i knew it could affect people
and also tone deaf because we do live in
like a new society that didn't exist
when you were on drake and josh and you
were yeah yeah there was no body
positivity then no not at all yeah um
okay so we're gonna do a whole segment
on the book i have literally so many
questions but before that let's dive
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
blue land did you know that an estimated
5 billion plastic hand soap and cleaning
bottles are thrown away each year and if
that's not bad enough each bottle can be
made of more than 90 water it's a
lose-lose situation for the planet and
blue land's idea is simple and beautiful
buy the bottle once refill it forever no
more plastic waste the only thing you
need to discard your outdated idea that
eco-friendly products are more expensive
and less effective just fill blue lands
beautiful instagramable bottles with
warm water pop in one of their hand soap
or spray cleaner tablets and within
minutes you have powerful cleaning
products in the most incredible sense
such as iris agave purine lemon and
lavender eucalyptus i use blue land in
my home it is stunning and it's great
for the environment and right now you
can get 20 off your first order when you
go to blueland.com
toast that's 20 off your first order of
any blueland products at blueland.com
toast blueland.com
oh right toast
also today's episode is brought to you
by modern fertility we've always been a
big fan of planning ahead scheduling
trips months in advance plotting our
next career move and you know what
fertility is something you gotta plan
also that's why monofertility was
created it's an easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get
personalized results within 10 days
you'll get insights into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve
which means how many eggs you have left
and other important factors the results
go deep into what every hormone means
and you can talk one on one with a
fertility nurse to review your tests and
options also if you have hsa or fsa you
can put those dollars toward modern
fertility right now modern fertility is
offering our listeners 20 off the test
when you go to modernfertility.com
toast that means your test will cost 139
instead of the thousands it could cost
at a doctor's office get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com
toast
modernfertility.com
toast all right josh let's dive in i
would love to hear your takes when i
asked you this morning like what you're
particularly interested in in pop
culture you said pete kanye is always
you know something you could talk about
always good um and i'm sorry like we we
every single day on this podcast we have
talked about
it just keeps happening yeah there's
something new and i'm sorry but like
this is a show where we talk about
what's going on in the world and what's
going on in the world is that a lot of
people have signed a petition to drop
kanye west as the coachella headliner so
his latest antics have prompted critics
to call on coachella to drop the rapper
as one of the music festivals 2022
headlines under the alias kim pete who
that's who started
um someone launched a change.org
petition saying that the organizers of
coachella should be ashamed of
themselves for giving west any more of a
platform to spew hatred towards his
ex-wife kim kardashian and her new
boyfriend pete davidson now there have
been uh 5 402 people who have signed
this which is not nothing but it's not
like it's a life-changing petition i
like how the page six is like so
dramatic you know it's not a movement
quite yet i want to start a petition and
just cancel coachella
you know what i don't like completely
agree i don't like force fun
i don't hate these fakakta outfits
agreed and you know what the food trucks
they're never as good as they they say
they're gonna be the lines for the food
out of control it's enough already have
you been i've never i've never been as a
silent protest
so you're canceling something you've
never even been to i you know
growing up because i moved to l.a when i
was 14 so at that time like coachella
was and i hate to be that old guy but
like it just seemed cooler it wasn't so
instagramable there was no instagram
yeah but they would still have like
these incredible headliners every year
right and now it's just become it it's
it's bigger than the music
it's not even about the music it's crazy
right it's as someone who's been twice i
can tell you it's and just i want to put
myself in defense mode both times i was
paid to be there or else i would never
have gone good for you it was
like okay i'm not gonna lie like i had
preconceived notions and the first time
i went i was like this is amazing like
it was like really fun but then the
second time i was like i can't believe
people do this for fun and people like
spend money like
i've been having to stagecoach
yes uh no but my i've not been but my
wife they loved it's a life-changing
weekend you're a country queen and i'm
here for it if there's one thing you
should know about me it's like i'm a
honky-tonk queen like you can find me on
broadway in nashville at any time that's
so funny because you were the hardest
core like beautiful jewish new yorker
i've ever met it's a unique crossover
and like i've i've been listening
country's becoming cool now but like i
was listening to like flyover states by
jason aldean in the ninth grade like
it's not it's not a front you know this
is who i am do you feel a connection to
the the message like of heartbreak like
what no
no and you know this because i've been
with ben since i was 18. it's not really
that i think i'm just like a how do i
put this i value
no
i like good music okay okay and i do
find that in you know certain pop songs
and certain genres i just don't feel
like they're good it's really as simple
as that
and if you go to a country concert and
you don't even like country music but
you can appreciate you know good music
good you know uh guitar playing it's
like
it's very it's to me it's just like a
lot of talent in a country music band
you know it's not like the click of a
button which it does take a lot of
talent i'm not you know dissing djs i'm
just saying we love you dead mouse we do
we're good with you diplo but it's like
real musical talent in my opinion i know
and but isn't it fascinating i find in
this with my wife's family too like if
you're a country person and you get into
a country person's car
country is on
that's it yes like me you get in my car
maybe it's hip hop maybe it's rock and
roll like it depends yeah you like
country
well that's you the thing is i have i
don't like to be put in a box and i feel
as though you're putting me in a box
right now what did i do i have it out
let's do it i do like country but like
if i'm getting in the car like we're
probably also going to listen to taylor
swift
kind of country adjacent i mean i i wish
she was still country adjacent but she
is not okay fair enough yes we'll be
listening to country but we'll also be
listening to um
pop top 40 ryan seacrest you know sure
i'm i'm kind of a woman of the world i i
support that and i think that country is
yeah i mean there's something about and
like i'll be like i'll listen to it and
my wife i'll talk to my wife and i'll be
like who cares about this coors light in
these trucks yeah no and she's
but she's like but you're listening to
like you know uh getting like platinum
chains and rolls-royces right like how
similar yeah different exactly i support
it by the way i didn't know that your
wife paige was country girly and now i
love her even more i'm so happy to hear
that i can't believe like your wife is
your wife like she's such a smoke show
she's a babe a good looking girl she's
just like what we like to call here at
the morning toast everything of the sort
she is pretty outstanding because she's
like i find women are obsessed with my
wife because she's very beautiful and
she's cool
so cool which makes no sense none
whatsoever do you consider yourself a
cool person
well i mean i i think at 35 now like
i've graduated to a point where like i
don't care anymore that's such a freeing
feeling i imagine because i'm still very
much wrapped up in the cool factor are
you oh a hundred percent you've never
met someone more insecure in your life
but also like incredibly secure you know
but is that the dichotomy of people like
us yes i think like i i think i'm known
a lot for my confidence and
what you might not know is like i would
say 50 to 60 of the time that confidence
is a facade
wow yeah i get that yeah i like in
meeting your husband i was like i
remember i i obviously i knew of you and
ben and i would watch him on on his
instagram stories and then i met him in
person i'm like you're so tall he's like
what do you think i was some short jew
and i was like that's amazing it was
like true and i was like and he has this
like
swagger to him that you have as well so
to hear that you also like have that
insecurity i think yeah i think that's
why you you know the people love you oh
josh come on
people love you you and ben went to
dinner last night ben got home and ben
was like i've literally never been to a
meal with someone who was asked to take
more pictures in his life he's like
people were asking for pictures on the
street in the restaurant chasing you
down to your hotel ben said it was chaos
it
it was it was a nice night
and in the book like you
there more like a lot of times like
you're very reticent to refer to
yourself as a celebrity or someone who's
famous even though like you have 12
million followers on instagram for a
while you were the most followed person
on vine you were in millions of homes
you still are like you are a famous
person and i just think it's time you
admit that
fine i'm going to do it here first on
the morning exclusive i josh
as i'm famous as frick you're famous
says frank do we don't curse here right
no
it's the internet famous is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass we don't want to get
demonetized we want to make it that's
true that's true yeah we want all the
ads all of them um but yeah i mean
because like i think especially being in
comedy and whatnot like i never i always
want to take the air out of the balloon
you know what i mean like the horse bill
um
bill burr always talks about like the
only thing worse than bombing on stage
is not acknowledging your bombing oh
right yeah that's that's a great quote
and in moments where like i went through
natural sort of ups and downs that every
sort of journeyman actor who's not tom
hardy goes through
like i it felt incumbent on me to be
like to call it out first much like the
chubby thing you know you're a hundred
percent right
and that makes a lot of sense yeah yeah
um so are you uh for people we don't
believe in cancer culture here but we
are extremely upset with kanye's
behavior while so many people are like
eating it up thinking it's like funny
it's abuse it's harassment and it's
really [ __ ] annoying and like i'm
personally done with kanye um do you
think that kanye should be uh canceled
from coachella
i don't know i don't know as much of the
intro like i've seen it from a top view
so i'd really have to see all the exact
exchanges to make like a definitive
decision because i never know with
people like kanye and kim and even like
pete to a certain extent they're they're
operating on such a lit a level of like
famous
moving sort of culture and the way like
like just they're turning all the knobs
and the buttons it's beyond like typical
celebrity it's like a taste maker
trendsetter
top 01 percent of famous people like
i've been upset before reading articles
and then the next day they'll be like
and then they were at disneyland right
i'm like you know what i'm not getting
on this ride you know what you're so
right like
because it's my whole life like we get
so personally vested in these stories oh
yeah and like then people just move on
yeah and you just don't know what like
they got into a small like kardashian
huddle about and they were like we're
putting this out tomorrow oh that i
don't buy that i don't buy no and i tell
me i think that like so much of the
rhetoric around like kim and all this
being a pr stunt and every time kim does
something it's like oh they're
distracting from you know jordan and
tristan i hate that first of all
because one it's kim's life so people
are like kim started dating pete to
distract from the travis scott um
drama at astroworld you think like kim
is making life decisions for herself for
her love life for her family who she's
bringing around her kids for pr like no
that's just not true and i think a lot
of those people who are like you know
the devil works hard but chris works
harder a lot of that is rooted in
misogyny like why can't like these six
women just live their lives without it
always don't get me wrong i think a lot
of times they're being you know
specific not calculated but meticulous
about how they're perceived but like
they're just six people trying to live
their lives and it's not always just
like a pr move and i just i really hate
when people genuinely think that
good to know i agree with you and i
gotta say in every exchange i've ever
had like in a tertiary way with the
kardashians everything i've ever heard
has been beyond lovely and they're all
incredibly impressive tell me which
kardashians you've met um i okay so i
met we met chris edward a party in paris
and she couldn't have been lovelier and
she was wearing a dress to die for and
she looks great in person great i love
that it's full support and i saw khloe
kardashian at a party and i was too
embarrassed to go up to her because i'm
josh from drake and josh
you're an icon living like you made it
out of the child star
whirlpool you're more famous now than
you were then like you should have went
up i know i should have and randomly it
was at maria menuno's birthday party
hollywood is so weird
it's so odd and i was like i don't know
even why i'm here but i i feel like i'll
allow chloe to live her life and
hopefully you know just have a drink and
a her moment um okay well speaking of
pete davidson second story of the day is
that pete davidson is now backing out of
the blue origin space mission earlier in
the week we uh reported that he was
going to be one of the passengers on
jeff bezos his you know it's like rich
people think they're sending people to
space and so pete davidson every rich
person is trying to like one up like you
know
uh richard branson got the youngest guy
so then pete davidson got the oldest guy
in the world to ever go to space
pete davidson is now not going i'm not
sure why but they're now they're like
rebooking his seat i don't know if he
got charged to change fee or anything
but he's not going
and i actually think there i could see a
world in which you are asked to go to
space and i want to know if you would do
it because you have so many followers
that have you like live stream the whole
thing you know i don't want to throw up
on live tv
and i know there's no way with the g's
and the amount of like it just sounds
terrible
so i mean bezos does seem like a fun
hang like i would love when he puts on
that cowboy hat it's over i want to know
what's going on in jb's mind but um
all in all i have no desire to leave
this earth i haven't even been to tokyo
yet right i want to see what's going on
here why space and i hear it costs quite
a pretty penny like a million bucks oh
well i think per pound i don't know
jackie once we read somewhere that per
passenger cost maybe a quarter of a
million dollars wow i don't know though
but i just do you think bezos was going
to pay for it or did pete davidson
no i don't think david i think this is
an influencer trip
it's revolve in the sky yeah exactly
fashion open sponsoring there
totally yeah i agree he's not paying for
it but he's not going anymore i mean i
like how he is full-time job as being on
snl he's uh never on it and now he's
just gonna leave the planet like you
have responsibilities down here he's
he's a you know i randomly had um lunch
with him at john and vinnie's in los
angeles a few years ago uh even before
he started dating ariana grande and
because he got in early
it just you know and now i'm not sure
whether he would remember me but
but eating dinner or lunch with him at a
very fancy italian spot in la it you
know i was like i know you because i
grew up in new york like i'm like your
kid from staten island right and it just
was so he couldn't have been nicer and
cooler and so now like sort of watching
from a farm like wow
it's crazy right and i also do you think
about i you probably don't think about
this because you're i feel like you're
comfortable because so much of your life
is with people like these huge
celebrities but like i was thinking
about like dating someone like kim
kardashian you know is the dream yeah
it's also kind of scary it's so scary
about being intimate with the most
beautiful woman in the world 100 and
also like here's what we don't think
about right
skims you know worth billions still
doing well very but if you're a good
dude you know you let her pick up the
private jet two three times right every
now and then you gotta be like this
one's on me i know and that's a two
hundred thousand dollar hit i know and
like obviously all these people are so
rich so it's like silly to even compare
but like
i think that the the gap in how much
money kim makes a year versus how much
money pete makes a year as like doing
stand-up uh he does some brand deals
he's calvin klein and then obviously
being on snl i think there's an enormous
gap
in their
salaries and i wonder how that affects
the dynamic when both people are
arguably like still so rich you know it
i mean i guess it just depends what your
baseline of sort of comfort and luxury
is right are you flying commercial are
you flying private do you think if you
got to that level would you i like
because to me i go listen i've had the
laydown on delta one it's lovely yeah i
don't need better than that i agree and
you're by the way you're a points guy
right i'm big points guys shout out
brian shout out brian i knew that about
you some well i wasn't until i met brian
and now i'm like such i could find a way
to fly literally from here to philly in
a lay flat bed like that's how
obsessed i am
and yes i agree like once you really get
to hack the system like there is a way
of flying commercial that's
not even close to be private but it's
fair pretty good fair oh yeah but also
kim has her own plane now she was just
reported she bought her own plane so she
doesn't need to charter anymore
gulfstream it's like sickening kim air
she's calling it it's the biggest plane
i mean it's not as big as drake's but
it's like the biggest thing i've ever
seen good for her yeah but the main
that's at least a million bucks a month
oh the hangar fees the gas you still
have to pay all the staff it's
incredibly expensive you know we all
have our challenges guys no and that's
what like people don't understand like
being kim kardashian is not easy no i i
i would never imagine that it's easy no
me neither and her superpower is
ambition and business sense and like and
i think people sleep on that because
they think like oh well it's just you
know it was oh she had a sex tape 500
years ago yeah it's ridic like you could
never do what she does never and
actually on the
last season of the kardashians she
actually said her superpower is her
calmness like she always remains calm
even in like crazy scandal family
anything she always remains calm and
that was like such an interesting take
because i would say her superpower is
like being smart being influential but
no she attributed all that to her
calmness
she's a whole package got to be more
calm
i need to be more confident i know but
we're jewish so we're like genetically
unable to be calm ever do you i'm i'm
very reactionary like i get like my i
can feel my heart twist yes and i go oh
this is bad i'm gonna need to eat
something yeah of course
me and ben were actually just every time
in the last week ben has said something
i'm like literally josh said that in his
book i need ben ben's not a huge reader
but i do want him to get him to read
your book you guys are so similar and
everything he was talking about how he
had on our day and he ordered so much
thai food he's like this is going to
make me feel better i'm like well
actually josh said in his book that he
used that as a coping mechanism and i
actually think ben would love the book
and i'm going to get him to read it i
have to tell you the cutest thing that
your husband said about you yesterday
which was congrats on your book
i'm going to read it which will be the
second book i've read since i was 13.
second to my wife's book you know that
like the book was it wasn't out yet but
it was finished and we had like bound
copies in our home for months sure
before and ben read it like the week it
came out just because like he didn't
want to be like not supportive it took
him so if then texts you in about 11
years and says he finally read your book
just know it's totally normal and it's
no slight to you bless him we'll get him
the audio book by the way i've heard
amazing things about the audiobook by
the way you narrate yourself right i do
yeah wasn't that a journey it's so i i'm
like when i'm listening to it back i'm
like wow i really have a list
you don't have a lisp do you i do a
little bit i have a bad i have an
underbite i got it i have no room for
the tongue got it got it have you ever
thought about you know speech therapy oh
no i did i went for years as a kid as a
kid but it's actually anatomical right
you can't fix it i have no room well i
could have my jaw broken should i do
that for a youtube video for you i mean
for the views for the schwa vlogs i
think maybe come on and then i'd have to
have braces for six months which would
be really cute would love that would
actually be like an amazing um
series on youtube like adults with adult
braces is like a really tough thing to
go through they did an episode of it on
sex in the city but it's something that
that is like not talked about well and
then i feel like all the adults have
have all the adults i know have
invisalign now yes and it's like i'm
like i can see your bracket
i agree and then when they like take it
out before eating i have a friend who
got married and like she finished her
invisalign it looked amazing but she
refused to stop wearing them until the
day of the wedding sure so everywhere we
went she was like like slurp it out it's
so disgusting like you have to do that
in the bathroom well i will say the one
have you watched the kanye dock on
netflix i watched part one so isn't that
the most endearing part is his retainers
no his retainers are the main character
of the documentary you're the best and
you know he has an amazing teeth he does
have really great but then i didn't get
to that part but he gets into an
accident or something and he has veneers
now right yeah he got he broke his shot
in an accident and then one of his
biggest songs through the wire is him
rapping while he's through the wire
wired shot oh interesting i didn't know
that i do mean to finish a documentary
but i've just found myself so inundated
with kanye bullshittery in the last
couple weeks totally i'm like i've had
i've hit my limit no i get it it's hard
it's not yeah
um okay i want to keep going because
this next story is beyond funny and it's
brought to you by gem nearly 90 of
americans are nutrient deficient there's
a massive misconception that just
because you eat healthy your body
doesn't need anything extra but gem is
made up of a blend of 15 plus whole food
ingredients that give you all the
essentials vitamins minerals adaptogens
superfoods prebiotics and probiotics to
address our modern lifestyle needs and
key deficiencies helping with total mind
body and support so if you feel like
you're not getting everything you need
especially when it comes to your mind if
you're feeling really cloudy throughout
the day adding gem into your daily
routine is something that might change
your life because i love a good
supplement because a really hard time
like eating fruits and vegetables
clearly and gem is a great way to
supplement all that if you want to check
out gem and try their seasonal favorite
citrus ginger daily try it yourself we
have special offer for the morning toast
listeners at
gemvitamins.com tmt
enter tmt at checkout for 30 off your
first order tmt is in the morning toast
that's gemvitamins.com
tmt for 30 off your first order thank
you jem for sponsoring today's episode
okay now in the latest news of hollywood
being so beyond out of control and out
of touch amy schumer says she pitched
the ukrainian president zielinski to
satellite into the oscars quote we have
so many eyes and ears on the show
so amy schumer she revealed this like
she brought it up herself
she revealed on the drew barrymore show
that she pitched the oscars producers on
having president zelecky satellite into
the show she said i'm not afraid to go
there but it's not me producing the
oscars so as we all know russia invaded
ukraine the zielinski the president of
ukraine zielinski was an actor and a
comedian before being elected head of
state which is just like a hilarious
story
um and she wanted to have him brought in
um and she thought that was such a good
idea even though it didn't happen she
thought she should tell everyone on the
drew barrymore show and i just think
this is peak
hollywood moronic behavior yeah like
really there's a [ __ ] war going on
and the president hold on let me
satellite into the oscars where
literally four people are watching now
right he's satellites in and he gives
this impassioned speech about what's
going on in the ukraine he goes and the
winner is house of gucci and the winner
is la la land yeah like that's it's it's
pretty it's pretty wild it's pretty out
of touch like to think that the oscars
are so and by the way i understand the
sentiment like you know it's a global
platform yada yada but first of all
nobody watches the oscars anymore like
every year we come on here and report
ratings from award shows and it's just
less and less and less and less like
when you compare the amount of people
who watch the super bowl to the amount
of people who watch it's just like not
even comparable so why do you think that
is i think that um especially in the age
of covid like when so many people were
going through like real [ __ ] problems
like nobody wants to watch the oscars
like it's just peak hypocrisy like
it's just it's so out of touch i think
that with the inventives like streaming
services we're just like all going
digital like movies are still super
relevant but they're just not what they
were like do you remember for me i
always bring up this example and jackie
has this running joke that i use like
the same four examples and this is one
of them please when i was in high school
like slumdog millionaire was the biggest
movie in the world it won every oscar
and it was like such a big deal yes and
it was so a part of the zeitgeist the
music and then the pussycat dolls did
jai ho like it was huge yeah and i just
can't remember in recent history where a
movie has like affected culture that
much right because we're just getting
with so many streaming channels i heard
some statistic that there's 490 tv shows
in production currently that is so crazy
that's insane that's insane i mean it's
good for people like you no looking look
thank god
lord but you know it's so true that
we're and i think award shows about
something subjective
just doesn't make sense i completely
agree like i love a fan voted moment i
do yes and i i yeah i don't know i mean
certainly like you know wouldn't mind an
academy award of course by the way me
neither don't take me out of the running
i could see you as an egot i could see
me as an egot too yeah an eclair a
glazed doughnut yum an onion ring and a
tell me
a tum because after all that i'm going
to need a tongue are you a tum scout
okay i wasn't a tums gal until i met my
husband and his family is like they're
tum people i never had a tum in my life
i don't think i'd ever really
experienced heartburn or else i would
have sought some sort of relief sure and
when i say my husband are tom's people
like they have costco-sized jugs in the
console of their car like oh yeah
everywhere and
as i got older when i started getting
hung hungover i started getting really
bad heartburn because i drink a lot of
like acidic margaritas like eastern
standards yeah sweet drinks sweet lots
of lemon delish and i think that that's
what's giving me heartburn and i would
wake up hungover with like this fire in
my throat i'm like ben what is it he's
like sweetie this is heartburn yeah
welcome and ever since i had my first
time like i cannot serve like when we go
on tour like we have this little kit of
things that we absolutely must have it's
filled with toms like i cannot live
without toms now i it's like those like
my car is like those tick tocks of like
um say like tell me you're jewish
without telling me you're jewish if you
go into my car and you go in the panel
there's a bottle of claritin got it
and it's just very like oh allergies and
heartburn like we we know what tribe
this kid's in 100 i love thomas like
ever since i started
and by the way they're atrocious to
consume no matter the flavor the
consistency is
chalky it's unique
yes it's like nothing i've ever tasted
before but how quickly it enter like it
intervenes what's going on right it's
literal magic i literally feel like i'm
i'm i'm ingesting like
police officers going to like break up a
riot 100 it's it's peace yeah
okay so amy schumer is out of touch we
already knew that in a little real oh
yeah where's i feel like she's coming
like she just has been a mom for a while
right she was a mom i think she had like
a lot of success really quickly and then
she took a couple years off she got
married she had a baby and i think like
you know it just totally takes a toll um
and now i think she's slowly coming back
she hasn't done a special in a while
since before she had a baby um she's
been very very low-key yes i agree and
okay and it's her and wanda sykes
and
uh was it just the two of them regina
hall i think yes let's see for the
oscars for the oscars i reported on it a
little while ago and i thought it was
actually a great how long until addison
ray and the dimelios host the oscars
regina hall and wanda sykes and honestly
i hope it's around the corner that yeah
that is a show i would watch that i'm
ready for it you have you hosted did you
host the are you you've presented at a
people's choice teen choice i've i
hosted teen choice and i got crazy small
resentment i've never hosted the kids
choice awards what how is this possible
that's so bizarre why are they doing
this do you have a kids choice award
yeah i got a couple you do i'm doing
okay where do you put them they're at my
mom's house that's so cute i'm dying
okay um since you said you're a
housewife girly lou angela steps was
drunkenly kicked out of a piano gay bar
over the week
so she was at townhouse in manhattan and
allegedly she grabbed the mic and
wouldn't stop one source says that
luanne was luanne thought she was doing
her act she tried to sing her own song
money can't buy you class but they
didn't know it and um she was asked to
leave she was wasted i think it's been
people have been curious if she was um
sober these last couple years she hasn't
been on tv in over a year um her
sobriety has been kind of murky since
her arrest she was sober but then there
was a lot of rumors she wasn't there was
an intervention she was sober again then
she started drinking so we don't know
where she landed but now we do she's
drinking she's drinking and she's at a
piano bar it's
arguably one of the best places to be
drunk agreed and it's a very common
thing sonja morgan was also kicked out
of a
establishment in
philly that i went to and i was like
this is the place it was like so
exciting i'm like this is the place
where sony morgan was kicked out i think
this is a rite of passage for new york
housewives new york housewives are all
drunks they're all messy and i'm curious
when you hear stories like this does it
really make you so grateful to be sober
i'm incred i mean yeah i'm incredibly
grateful to be sober i mean i mean i
literally out myself in this book beyond
about you know me sowing my wild oats
and being a total cliche in hollywood
for four years but you know when i was
getting drunk and acting a fool like i i
there was no camera phones i know i was
thinking about that what were the years
you said four years in the book where
you were like very into drugs and
alcohol what year was that probably like
oh just around when i turned 18 to 21.
what years in the world was that that
was 20 or 2000 i got children in 2008 so
oh yeah 2004 to 2008. oh so that's when
i was in the fourth grade so there was
no there were no no i always think of
that like i didn't have a
camera phone in the fourth grade unless
anyone was like throwing out their
t-mobile sideways right right quick but
so no you're right you should actually
that's something to be really grateful
for like oh yeah if you think of like
some of the videos and pictures that
could have surfaced of you in your
darkest times i mean there's like one or
two pictures of me just like holding a
beer like looking a little sauced a
little bit of a lush i can't lie when i
was reading the book i did google like
looking for pictures because were you
ever arrested no no okay well i thought
maybe that was coming so i was like josh
peck mugshot got it then nothing came up
and then i was like joshua peck mug shot
still nothing came up good for you i
like your googling i know i know but no
it's something to be entirely grateful
for that you went through that time not
at the peak of like people celebrities
having no privacy yeah i just like and
you know a lot of people will say to me
they're like oh i was an alcoholic when
i was 20. right like it's not the same
it's not the same especially after
hearing some of the stories that you
write in the book about
the incident where you were chased by
the police that was [ __ ] crazy like a
little bit crazy and the incident where
like right after you left the house of
someone you were picking up drugs from
like that person was stabbed yeah it was
it was hectic i got so lucky i i you
know i've been sober for a long time and
i did it through 12-step and i remember
this guy said something to me he was
like this older guy in his 80s he's like
you're here because of your mother's
prayers
oh he's like not you didn't do anything
right here this is because because of
you're one of the lucky ones and forces
outside of you got you here and i'm like
it's so right because you're right like
i was a second away right and you and at
that time nothing scared you like
nothing that happened could have scared
you into stopping because i had been
first of all i'd like been overweight my
whole life so then i'm like suddenly in
the body of what i think is like a cool
normal typical person and i'm like and
cool normal typical people aren't you
know people with a career at nine right
they're people who act to fool at 19
yeah and and aren't worried about like
you know upsetting their parents and and
they just they go crazy and that's what
i did i thought i was like i remember i
talk about in the book like the first
time i did drugs it wasn't for the
effects it was because it was a girl
yeah it was for a girl and i was like oh
this is so normal yeah and i'd been
dying to be normal because every time
i'd get invited out by by a girl or to a
party i'd be like i would love to but i
have to stay home and alphabetize my
dvds i can't do it
were you a were you like a party kid in
in your teams or college years i'm okay
so i'm still technically like living in
my party era
i did grow up in the city so it was like
very fast sure um
in a good way not in a bad way like i
didn't really see much like no one was i
went to a jewish high school so no one
was like snorting lines you know what i
mean like we were we were fast but not
as fast as some of the other schools in
the city um
and i went to nyu
which was not really it was four years
of like honestly nothing i feel like i
actually really missed out on a college
experience i lived at home for the last
three years because i dorms the first
year i'm like i live in the city this is
a waste of money and like i hate all
these people and they hate me so like i
basically just went to class and i had
just met ben so like we i spent all my
years in college hanging out with them
like it wasn't a crazy time in my life
sure and then once we got married i was
like ready to party so that's the era
i've been in since i got married was
there ever a thought of like you know
what i'm gonna go to the university of
kansas no that you weren't gonna go to a
city school i grew up in a strict house
and like really all my sisters went to
nyu we really it wasn't that we weren't
allowed it was just like what are you
doing leaving the family like stay you
know my sister jackie went upstate new
york that's like the furthest anyone
went which was crazy no uh colgate hmm
yeah a liberal arts moment fun
nice
um okay we've got one more story right
before we dive into the book and it's
specific for you because you're our
social media star tick tock is rolling
out snapchat style stories for more
users
so their experiment with snapchat style
style stories is continuing with the
company further rolling out the feature
to a larger group of users today if
you've gotten the feature you'll be
greeted with a new banner when you
launch the app encouraging you to create
a story in a statement they said
currently we're expanding a pilot test
which provides creators with additional
formats to bring their creative ideas to
life in the tik-tok community so um this
is something a lot of platforms twitter
did it facebook did it i think they both
have been shut down since then right
instagram did it they stole it from its
snapchat and it was enormously
successful do you think that this will
work you're on tick tock you're pretty
big i do well on tick tock i think if
anyone can figure out anything it's
tick-tock i agree they just seem to know
and they have a like their finger on the
pulse of the culture like they know what
the kids want they listen to the kids
and they they really can't be stopped
yeah i just think it and if it was ever
gonna work i mean it's it's in a place
like tick tock like you just weren't
going to twitter for stories ever ever
or you never also we're not going to
facebook and i mean what about what do
you think of the subscription model um
for twitter like twitter blue i think
they call it i mean it's not a bad idea
but i think anything twitter tries to do
at this point is just irrelevant like
they are a dead company in the sense
that like i don't think they're ever
really gonna grow i think they'll be an
important part of like the social
atmosphere because it's really the only
platform where you can break news right
so it has that and i think it's good for
like a few things but i don't think
they'll ever really evolve past that and
i think once they acknowledge that and
stop trying like it'll be so much better
for all of them which is why they should
turn to like a subscription model for
people like
cnn yeah who are like updating it every
five minutes and say well it's gonna
cost you a hundred thousand dollars a
month to be on this platform and they'll
do it yes i think the big platforms will
do that i think that'd be a great
revenue thing for them but i think for
the user experience like we're as
consumers like we're never going to use
twitter differently yeah it's so it is
what it is twitter spaces twitter they
could try all they want like no one's
doing it it's not twitter voices they
try to copy like a clubhouse and green
room like no one's buying what they're
selling no we just want the two two we
just want the breaking news yeah the 280
yeah now we're at 280. yeah cute um okay
so actually have you gotten the feature
yet i feel like you would be one of the
first people
yeah i'm going to be definitely going to
feel really insecure if i didn't get it
me too because it would be really
upsetting it'd be a huge huge blow to
your ego oh dear no i didn't get it no
would i know right away let's see yeah
they say like a banner would pop up at
the top this is unacceptable
you got to talk to your people wait
nah nothing i got a top i got a
monetization top brand request from
handheld vacuums oh wow did you do a
sponsorship with them things are looking
up
okay well speaking of sponsorships
that's a great way to segue into the
next sponsor for today and your book
which is all about money which i loved
by the way the transparency so money is
brought to you by movement movement has
expanded into blue light glasses that
protect your eyes from screens
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank and
they're all designed out of their
california headquarters so they're blue
light glasses i wear blue light glasses
before bed because i scroll tick tock
watching josh's videos for 45 hours
before i actually fall asleep i watch a
lot of tv and that's so bad for your
eyes and it helps you it doesn't help
you fall asleep if you're wearing a blue
light glass it will protect the ones
from movement are incredibly stylish and
they get the job done so if you work all
day in front of a computer the
everscroll blue light filtering glasses
are a game changer they really help with
eye strain and poor sleeping patterns
and i love the modern style of the
frames if you want to elevate your look
with style that doesn't break the bank
then join the movement and get 15 off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt.com
toast again that's m b
t
toast check out their new minimalist
jewelry their style essentials and of
course the blue light glasses okay your
book happy people are annoying by josh
peck came out this week yes how has pub
week been been for you good i think yeah
i think so too i've been seeing you
everywhere oh wow bff's pod gma like
you're you're everywhere i was with the
the view gals yesterday by the way what
was that like i okay here's here's a a a
wonderful little you know little bite of
something a little t i go and and i i
forget and i'm talking you know to the
to the host before and i'm like looking
at the chair and i'm i'm sitting there
and i'm like oh this this swivels a lot
and one of the hosts goes like you
understand why joy could fall joy fell
the other day and i said that's
incredible
i was like i can't believe i am at the
scene of the crime did they grill you i
feel like it's such a scary show to be
on were you scared they couldn't have
been lovelier oh good okay yeah i mean
they were so lovely and and
you're right i was i was certainly like
intimidated just because
you know the show you're unique in the
sense that you've been on the internet
for so long and you've been killing it
on the internet for so long and you've
really never i don't want to jinx you
but you've never been cancelled
no you don't have scandals knock wood
knock wood knock wood knock wood
government i mean yeah i i certainly
like no more scandal than something i
talked about in the book right that's
true that's true and and like you i like
feel so lucky that i met my wife 10 11
years ago almost like she was 20 i was
24. right so it's like i've kind of been
a family man for a long time yeah before
my son was born so
and the the truth of the matter is it's
like i love famous people like you and
ben i love people who are humans thank
you no big deal no it's just i'm a star
like i like people in the industry where
we can like actually have real
conversations but like the people that
are operating up there where like you
talk to them and you're like are you a
robot right is there anything here right
it doesn't super interest me i just like
working and hanging out with my family
100 okay so speaking of family the first
thing that i thought about your book was
i literally loved how you wrote about
your mom oh and i loved that she was a
thread throughout the whole book in the
sense that like you wanted success so
bad and not for the reasons that i think
typically most people want success fame
money access like you just really wanted
to be able to take care of your mom and
that was like a thread the whole time
given how you grew up and just kind of
um sometimes unstable environments and
like you really just wanted to grow up
and be the one to protect your mom and i
just like i found myself tearing up so
much every time you spoke about your mom
it was
so lovely oh thank you and how is your
mom my mom is the best shout out barb
shout out barb is the best she's 77
she's totally crushing it we got on the
phone after i finished dinner with your
lovely husband yesterday and this is her
i just and you know she's been watching
the view i go i she goes so tell me
that's how she opens the call
so tell me did you was she like shipping
so much in office with you on the view
the amount of knocks i'm gonna read you
some of the texts i got from my mom
yesterday because i feel like you
painted such an ad like a picture of her
like i lit i don't even know what she
looks like but i know she was about okay
here we
go just saw the view i'm beyond proud
i'm fake plot seed and overwhelmed
that is beyond funny okay that's at 1 55
p.m at 3 12 p.m jeez the outpouring is
awesome honey you are so loved oh my god
i'm crying and then i go i write thank
you and then three minutes later did you
get a new york slice or a bagel
it always comes back to food always
comes back that's your like i'm you know
i have this really small part in this
christopher nolan movie that i've been
working on then told me about it and i
you know i'm so honored to be there and
it's like you know matt damon and all
these crazy people and and you know it's
like a proper big like i've certainly
done some indie movies where yes
where i was like where's my dressing
room
you're in it i'm like we're outdoors
what's going on and
so my mom calls me and it's my first day
she goes so
they pick you up
and i go
yeah ma
they picked me up what kind of car it's
a christopher nolan movie like i got in
a van and they drove me to set they're
like they provide lunch
yes there was a lunch was it good it was
good like that's all she wants to know
what's the spread right of course
and are you getting home safe yes
totally um what i found to be so
interesting and i i love celebrity
memoir books they're like my favorite
genre but to be honest like sometimes i
do find myself like skipping through
people's upbringing because like who
[ __ ] cares
but
first of all your upbringing is so
interesting one because of the whole
thing with your dad which we'll get into
in a minute and two because you were a
star and i had no idea that as like a 12
year old you were going to clubs in new
york and doing stand-up yeah that's
insane i didn't even know they had kid
hour stand up we so i started getting
into stand-up because i found there was
this thing called backstage magazine
which was like the actors magazine in
new york and in the back there'd be
classifieds and i read at nine years old
it says sid gold at gold star
entertainment we rep comedians of all
ages right i said well i'm of all ages
so i go to meet him and he's like you
know if you can get five minutes
together i can get you booked at a club
so i like steal jokes from my mom make
fun of kids at school and suddenly i'm
performing at stand-up new york
caroline's right yeah that's insane were
you getting paid for that no but like
you were just doing it to warm up your
craft have sid believe in you yeah i
just wanted to get sid some some
eventual commission wow that's so crazy
i never even heard of anyone doing
stand-up that young that's insane and
then i like wound up doing it like on
the uh well i don't think i talk about
this in the book so at the time the
rosie o'donnell show was she was like
the first ellen yeah i remember biggest
thing in the world
and my mom and i just loved it and we
get tickets right
so and every every episode she would
have someone from the crowd introduce
her oh wow so my mother
god bless barb we're standing there and
she sees a guy running around with like
a headset on she goes listen
i got somebody for you
10 year old comedian
done deal rosie's gonna love him like
have him introduce her
five minutes later we're in the green
room
yeah we we went from the line to the
green room that's gonna be the next book
and and we're sitting there and my mom's
like giving me the look like you know
what to do right you don't just say what
they tell you to say you say what you
got this is your moment and i i wound up
doing stand-up on her show that morning
that's such a crazy story it was so and
then i did did it on conan o'brien and
like all these things and yeah it was it
was my thing i didn't know that yeah um
obviously i knew about the amanda show
and the drake and josh of it all which
you do go into in depth and at that
point in your career when you started
having like real traction with the kids
show is when you were at your heaviest
totally and i just about lost my mind
when you divulged like the day you were
introduced to spanx
yeah on set of drake and josh with the
wardrobe manager because you were just
like not feeling it and she put this
thing on you and you immediately were
just smoothed out and like it gave you
confidence
i i yeah i reveal like this is
2002. so there's like there's no spanx
there's no skims
there's just like the macy's shapewear
department totally yeah and so
uh shout out chris she was a wardrobe
designer she was like the loveliest
woman loved me and kind of knew that
like you know it i i just was i was
playing kind of a thankless role at
times yeah you know a little bit the
butt of the joke at times punching bag a
little bit and and so basically like my
go-to look was a big t-shirt and sort of
like a shirt over that open nice you
know slimming yep yep middle line yep
and so she was and she could just tell i
would like pull up my clothes and i
would sort of close myself off in scenes
trying to cover i don't even know if i
was aware of it so one day she says come
here i want you to go in i want you to
put on this tank top and it's like
flesh-colored right it's like this tuna
like there's threads popping out because
she's manufacturing oh that's so sweet
yeah and i go in and i'm like this is
way too small unless i'm like putting it
on i'm like this woman's a chubby
like chaser obviously trying to like
embarrass me right and then she's like
now put the shirt on over it and i was
like oh my god
and i i think i say in the book like i i
went from like having a muffin top to
looking like an overly stuffed bag of
bread right smooth but it was smooth
right and i was like i felt like i wore
that from 297 pounds to
170 pounds wow like and then eventually
i found calvin klein made one right that
you said i
upgraded but yeah god bless her oh my
god i just love that i was like where is
the story going i'm like spanx spanx
male 1
um and then you really talk about how
you made the decision to lose the weight
and how you kind of thought that would
like fix your whole life like all your
problems you've ever had would be solved
and
of course it wasn't and then that's how
your food addiction turned into a drug
addiction um and i just i was shook
because i know you i know this josh we
met like what like a year ago i was i
just can't picture you being that josh
being chased by the police picking up
drugs and random like it was just
shocking and it was shocking how honest
you were
yeah i i don't i i think in writing it i
didn't realize it and now sort of the
reaction i'm like wow maybe i did you
know it did divulge a little much but i
you know with certain moments like i
tell these you know specific stories
about losing weight and the drug stuff
and then like career mishaps and
and i was working with a buddy of mine
who was sort of i knew i didn't want a
ghost writer but i needed an advisor on
help yeah someone i could bother and he
said to me he's like if you don't get
honest and really tell your story here
like a people aren't gonna care and b
you're not gonna help anyone right and
so yeah i i basically like i lost 110
pounds and suddenly i was in
the same head in a new body right it
didn't go away yeah i didn't have like i
throughout so many times in my life
before i got comfortable with who i was
i imagine that if i get to this finish
line old josh will just evaporate and
like this new confident like men about
town will arise
and and it was only an impre it's it's
it's really some like chubby jewish
spider-man [ __ ] yeah it's only an
embracing my origin story that i really
was sort of freed
i love that that's gorgeous thank you
and by the way what i really loved is
when you spoke about a lot of the drake
and joshua you spoke a lot about the
money yeah because there's this
perception i mean when you think about
how relevant that show was how many
millions of people have seen it you
would think that you're living in a
palace you have gold bars for breakfast
like you would think that but you really
broke down the money you said over the
course of five years because there
aren't that many episodes on kids tv
shows you made 450 000 over the course
of five years which after taxes after
commissions for your agents and everyone
that netted to what like less than a
hundred thousand dollars a year yeah so
we made 900 000 over five years and then
it netted to about 450 over five so yeah
it was a little less than 100 grand a
year right which isn't what you would
expect for someone who's like so a part
of the cultural site guys hug me brother
like it's like it's so a part of pop
culture yeah you would think like you
were making bank but you weren't no and
and is that did you think that too like
of course
you were like hannah montana level like
yeah it was a and i'm sure i i doubt
miley got rich from that show exactly
she got rich for [ __ ] by the
way and you don't get paid royalties in
kids television shows which i didn't
know until i read your book and
is drake and josh on a streaming service
right now probably probably on what like
paramount plus viacom right um
so the show is still generating revenue
and you're not no nothing ever like the
day we were done it was done and yeah
and it was like because i think like we
hear about the kids from modern family
or two and a half men yeah and like yeah
that's you know
f you money for the rest of your life
and then like nowadays we also have like
like the stranger things kids yeah
whether they get paid or not i'm sure
they're doing great
also when stranger things dropped on a
friday when they woke up monday they had
10 million followers a different life
yeah and then you know now absurd
amounts so like suddenly they had this
tangible thing that they could take with
them monetize but we didn't have that
necessarily so yeah like it you know
obviously i don't want to talk about
money it's gross but it felt important
no it's beyond helpful by the way yeah
explain and what's so interesting is
like you were at nickelodeon at this
time where like now years later we all
grew up with it it's kind of been like
this like source of scandal in a way
amanda bynes you got started on the
amanda show before drinking josh do you
talk to amanda at all like how is she
doing we stand her so hard and we just
want her out of her conservatorship i
absolutely love her okay we do we'll
like talk every year or two and she was
the best then and she's like the best
now i just i feel like amanda bynes was
robbed in so many ways because i think
the industry whatever happened to her
that led to her
cracking down
robbed us all and robbed her because i
think she was on her way to being like
the comedic actress of our generation
beyond the movies that she did up until
that point she's the man like oh my gosh
it's jesus it's she she was the funniest
actress and i just so want her to be
well my friend brandon j mclaren who he
and i did the show turner and hooch
disney plus he was one of the stars of
she's a man and i'm like we're never
which character he played he was like on
the he was on the soccer team and he was
like one of channing's
guys yeah yeah one of the dudes and like
he i'm like we're never gonna not talk
about that yeah i want to know
everything because that movie is iconic
i mean i use she's the man jargon in
everyday life word gmon
my favorite spree like literally my
favorite scooter um but okay so the
amanda binds of it all right also i have
to ask because for years i have
i actually when i when our show used to
be owned by verizon i got like in so
much trouble from legal for talking
about dan schneider but there have been
like so many especially in the age of
tick tock like the feet
there is a lot of weirdness as it
pertains to dan schneider and i i can't
lie i was gooped and gagged seeing his
name in your book i want to know what
you think of the dan schneider of it all
i mean obviously i've certainly seen
seen that stuff just it being around in
the public but you know my experience
with with him was he was my boss you
know and he was certainly like i mean he
at that time what what is sort of you
can't deny is that he had the magic
sausage
i mean he was behind kingdom and kel and
all that amanda victorious
yeah and so
he was certain he's like i know what i'm
doing and and there's no question that i
know what i'm doing and so you know we
weren't we weren't that close it just
was like he was my boss and and i kind
of like and and i was going through so
much of my own stuff at that time that i
think i was like if i you know i i just
was sort of so self-focused okay yeah
okay so you didn't see anything
nefarious no okay but then there's the
drake of it all which i really don't
want to get into because if you read the
book and i feel like a lot of the press
you've been doing everyone wants to know
about drake drake drake but if you read
the book like it's not that deep like
you guys started working together and
then after the show some people you know
keenan and kell they went on as a comedy
duo you guys decided to go your separate
ways but did keenan and kell go on as a
comedy dude i don't know but like you
and drake didn't and you didn't keep in
touch and you got married 10 years later
and you didn't invite him to your
wedding because like would you invite
your coworker from 10 years ago to your
wedding no
and then he went crazy and now he's in
jail or whatever like it ain't that deep
like you didn't get him to your wedding
not because there was some big beef
because you had a small wedding and you
hadn't spoken to the man in 10 years
i you know again i was going through
such a weird random existence during
that time and like and like so i'm like
deeply insecure being overweight on this
show and like and also but like why how
am i crying with two loaves of bread
under my arm that i'm eating
[Laughter]
like i'm this is the dream like i wanted
this i got us out of new york like we're
not broken right you did it and it
wasn't like enough it wasn't enough yeah
and then and then i lose the weight and
i'm dealing with this weirdness which is
like
some most people were very happy for me
but now i'm getting hate for losing
right right right you can't win and i'm
like well talk to my cardiologist right
right i did what i did like i'm no
longer on blood pressure meds um can we
talk about your dad please and okay so
crazy story by the way about your dad
how you're you never met him no you know
existed and like i think now you
probably like know his name and maybe
what he looks like but he's passed on
yes and the book is very eerily
dedicated
for e a d
are those your dad's initials they're
not my dad's initials but more
importantly they're not my mother's
initials
and i've heard about that from her who
the [ __ ] is this this is a lovely very
special family friend who helped
my mom's best friend who helped raise me
got it and she sadly passed away and
and it felt like sort of like and she
to be quite honest she passed away at
the time where i was kind of like you
know acting a fool
so i i felt like i never quite was able
to give her the
her do you know and i love that i felt
like a loving tribute oh my god i have
chills i love that okay i thought maybe
it was like some sneaky message just
like
my dad
i'm gonna dedicate this thing i worked
so hard on
well so the dad thing was so crazy
and what i thought was so interesting is
like you said it really affected you as
an actor like in roles where you would
have to like talk to your dad you felt
weird because you'd never spoken to a
dad before totally and i thought that
was interesting and then i was like
dying because you and the book came out
before
the book was sent to the publisher
before this news was released you are
now in how i met your father yes and a
lot of people think you might be the
father and it's just to me i was like
laughing so hard because i'm like this
whole dad complex you had and then you
ended up on a show how i met your father
where you might be the father i don't
know yeah i mean and now i'm i'm i'm
very much at the dad age like and you
are a dad i am a dad i'll see like you
know you get these things called
breakdowns for auditions and it'll be
like you know the part is 30 to 40 you
know
um a
guy you know a typical looking guy and
and now it says and he's a dad to an
eight-year-old i'm like that's
impossible
maybe it is so yes it's weird yeah i
never met my pops it certainly had this
sort of big effect on me but in so many
ways i didn't realize and then in having
my own kid it like really allowed me to
sort of like close that bad feedback
loop and you never reach out to any of
his siblings you said in the book that
you did that i mean not siblings kids
any of your siblings you said in the
book you did that on purpose like you
know you could reach out to them but you
don't want to blow up their entire world
like hey
i'm here welcome
you know
um i you know the truth is is yes he had
a whole other family and he was in his
60s when he hooked up with my mom so
it's like he you know my brothers and
sisters are in their 50s and
so yes that is certainly a thing where i
was like i had done so much work on it
and he was gone at this point that i'm
like i don't want to blow up their image
that they have of their dad right he was
obviously great to them i mean that's
incredibly magnanimous of you like not
everyone aren't you curious i i'm not so
curious but my a buddy and i brought
this up my friend brian koppelman who
had me on his pod and it was an
interesting insight he's like
do you ever think though
that you also hold secrets that might
help them right and i was like what do
you mean he's like
that his kids might in the back of their
head go you know sometimes dad would
come home
smelling a perfume right or like
sometimes dad would have this like lost
look in his eye and i'd wonder what he
was thinking and like if i showed up and
i was like that lost was josh from drake
and josh i mean it's not enough that
like they have this other sibling but
it's you like it's crazy odd well so
have you ever done 23 and me i have yes
they might find you that way
you're in the registry yeah
wow did you not think about that no when
i was reading the book i'm like did this
[ __ ] do 23andme i gotta go
no i'm like i'm having a melody no that
would be amazing all 23andme told me was
i was like 99.1 ashkenazi okay by the
way so like
in like i grew up in and i still like
very much socialize in like a really
jewish community here in new york and
one of my best friend's dads was like
98.9 percent and people were freaking
out like that was the highest state
scene 98.9 percent ashkenazi jewish so i
do it and i'm 99.6
wow and i'm like one-upping kenny
astronaut if i'm like kenny i'm the new
queen mazel wait then ben does it
100
ashkenaz jewish isn't that crazy i just
can't believe that like a his great
great great great didn't have like an
affair yeah you know it's shocking with
a polish girl or like somebody like
chick's a goddess yeah some beautiful
shiksa goddess okay so now let's talk
about your transition into being an
influencer content creator whatever you
want to call it yeah i was shook first
of all because when you were talking
about the first time you ever made money
on a brand deal and you were talking
about badou like i've been influencing
for so long like i have badou stories i
got paid 25 grand from badoo like
i was shook reading that like just the
parallels i'm sure it was a similar time
like it was so funny like a real
throwback so i love that yeah um
and i didn't realize like at the peak of
your career with like the vine not peak
of your career peak of the vine career
sure we were the most followed person on
the platform these brand deals were just
coming in left right and center before
it all came to a halt and now even after
i didn't realize what a big part of your
like digital career college talks were
yeah you get paid for that oh yeah a lot
nice
wow not bad i'm sure would you do that
duh i mean i think i'm like too
like disgusting to speak at a college
like i cannot believe that i've done
some hellos
you'd crush i love a hillel good bagel
spread i love they fly you first class
for the college talks they basically
will they'll give you a fee and then
like they'll say like and this you know
and then you have like a stipend a part
of it and you know fly yourself put
yourself up wherever that's why you're a
points guy i always go nice on the plane
and i go simple on the hotel i think
that's a really good philosophy i'm a
marriott courtyard guy are you a barrier
bon voy member of course of course the
app is so good oh i'm dying for titanium
no i know i'm a few nights away from
like reaching my next level and it's so
helpful with tour because i got so many
hotel rooms i couldn't wait oh i shout
out marriott shout out marriott speaking
of your digital career i found it very
interesting that you were incredibly
specific and upfront about how much
money you made on tv but then when it
came to the money you were making on
social you were a little more
tight-lipped and i think that's because
you're making a lot of money on social
can you explain your decision well i
yeah i i think like i i think i say at
one point like it it there came a point
where i was making seven figures from
youtube a month
not from youtube no no not a month no
over like a year i could i was making
over seven figures with like combined of
brand deals and college and speaking
engagements but yeah i was able to yeah
and at that point it's just like you're
playing with house money like it just
makes no sense because it's you know in
comparison it's just like it you're
we're the lucky ones 100
that i was like it's not important that
i like put some weird flecks yeah but i
was curious i'm not gonna lie i'm nosy
we're friends yeah no i guess i could
have just texted you like how much did
you get paid for that brand yeah um okay
keep going i thought that was really
interesting at the end of your chapter
on sobriety and like your journey to
going to meetings
was this little disclaimer you had
because alcoholics anonymous is of
course anonymous and in some way like
does it contradict the anonymity of it
all by writing about it in the book i
thought it was totally fine i know of
course you probably changed all those
people's names like i thought it was
fine i'm curious if people since the
book came out a few days ago if you've
had any sort of backlash to you writing
about it i haven't and you're right like
how could i tell in an honest way
my experience while honoring the
anonymity of 12 step and so i do mention
it but it's not a lot and i basically
yeah there's certainly there were ways
where i could have omitted it completely
but i feel like i maybe wouldn't have
been able to tell the whole story yeah
so i feel like and that's why i did do
the disclaimer because reality is like
in no way am i a representative or an
ambassador for any 12 sub it's just
something that worked for me and i i
have that quote in the stevo book or or
in the book about what stevo said which
is like
whenever someone you know puts on weight
no one blames the gym right right like
they just assume they stop going right
so i think it's important because you
know it's a day-to-time thing that like
i say that i'm sober today hopefully i
will be for the rest of my life and you
know i i got sober this way but there
are other ways do you still go to
meetings i do do you go when you're in
new york or you stay in l.a i i'm only
been here two days but if i'm traveling
somewhere i'll totally look up it's a
great way to like just plug in to people
that are like me and yeah speaking of
the stevo quote what i also found really
interesting in the book was how many
quotes you had whether it was like
things people in your life have told you
that that stuck with you
um
famous quotes by like famous doctors now
i wanted to know if you research those
quotes or you have them all memorized
well i also i had a podcast i have my
podcast male models now but for 120
episodes i did the curious podcast so i
had a lot of great stuff from people i
was fascinated by and i sort of mind
that and then but then also yeah i i i'm
a quote guy i love a good quote and then
also i would look up some stuff and you
know yeah i found the quotes to be like
extremely powerful i literally if you
look at this book i have so many things
underlined ready oh boy i love it look
at you no i was i really okay
i don't know you said uh who said this
was it lisa lampanelli
oh that's a great that was on my podcast
i don't know about the the popcorn trick
no the reason why people are funny is
usually not funny at all i don't know if
that that's a great quote but i don't
know where i where you heard it from
okay oh also um i loved when you talked
about tv being your best friend yes and
i resonated so hard with this like
throughout my life television has been
my best friend my babysitter my teacher
and most importantly my escape i left um
i left it on to feel like someone was
there i fell asleep to it so the room
never got dark if you knew like how much
i've been doing that since i was a kid
mostly because i'm afraid of the dark
like when ben's gone i sleep with the tv
honestly with all the lights i'm like
i'm my electricity bill is crazy because
i'm petrified absolutely petrified of
the dark i just i love that and i was
like oh my god this is in my brain wait
let me keep going hold on while you look
i'll tell you that now
my my wife and i have recently purchased
a home mazel tov thank you so much and i
am a city kid i've grown up in
apartments we live in an apartment
currently and i am so terrified that now
if there's a sound in the house it's
going to be incumbent on me
oh yeah you should go investigate i
could never live in a house so many
sounds i remember
p this was years ago paige's mom my
wife's mom was uh she's like you know
your father's out of town and i've been
hearing a lot of sounds around the house
like there've been people walking around
like i'm just feeling a little nervous
like would you guys mind staying over
the night right i'd love for a man to be
in the house tonight and i was and i'd
go well
a man
i was like
i'm not that guy and i was like geez
when a man is required i am now of the
eighth yeah you have to come to terms
with that oh my god speaking of paige i
have two more questions for you speaking
of paige i was kind of waiting in the
book for you to talk about like your
guys's meet cute but from a lot of the
press i've seen you do this week and
just like overall consensus from the
book it's my understanding that paige is
extremely private she i wouldn't say
extremely but she's she's a healthy
amount of pride right and it's it's just
something i love about her because she
she so knows who she married and she in
no way ever tries to i mean she censors
me in the way a wife should sense of
course which
but she's just like i'm happy to be
along you know for the ride and and in
certain instances like join you with
with things but you know she she's a
private person yeah and i do love that
about her
and we also made the call early on
because i was just being a total like
proud dad and i loved posting photos of
my kids yes and you know the internet
loves it yeah you heard the views right
um but you know around two-ish we're
like he's got a face now it you know i
wanted to honor his anonymity so i don't
post them anymore we were just talking
about that earlier on the podcast
because i come from a family now we have
two kids in our family and we don't
share on social media it's like from
from day one it's just like a general
rule of thumb and i think like once
you've seen the internet good and bad
like i think a lot of people would come
to that decision and i totally respect
that decision yeah i just think like if
i want to give him the choice of
anonymity because i think that's a right
and privacy and if at a certain age when
he's old enough to be like dad i want to
be in something
great great but he can't make that
decision right now totally the last
thing i want to talk to you about is
this concept in your book of apostles i
which is such like a non-jewish thing i
was like what the [ __ ]
but
i loved that concept i feel like i have
something similar similar in my life i
refer to as like hashem like an angel of
god like people who just bring you from
one place to another and i feel like you
had a similar thing with apostles just
people in your life who have told you
really really hard truths and i'm
curious how as a jew from new york you
can i didn't even know what the [ __ ] an
apostle was until i read it in your book
i had to google it like how did the [ __ ]
did you know that and how did you come
to that
uh theory i well i tell this story about
i was doing this movie called the
wackness with ben kingsley and he's my
favorite actor he's like the michael
jordan to me of acting and and i
remember on the last day of filming i i
just felt compelled i was 20 i was you
know not sober and i needed a father
figure
and i'm like and i remember i said to
him i was like
sir ben because he's a knight you call
him sir
i said do you have any advice and he
looked at me and
i wanted the secret i was like how do i
become a movie star right and he was
like find your apostles and i was like
right i didn't learn about that in
hebrew school
and you know i've learned that an
apostle is someone who tells you they're
willing to hurt your feelings to tell
you something that's going to be good
for you that will better you i always
say
if if your reaction to something is my
reaction to an apostle telling me
something is always um
screw you
i'm the worst you're probably right but
it's too late right fine i'll do it
right and
throughout my life i've had people in my
life who were willing to hurt my
feelings knowing that it was going to be
the best thing for you yeah but yeah i
didn't know i mean i'd heard of apostles
i knew that you know the virgin mary and
joseph was a carpenter yeah i knew that
too you know or like maybe he would joe
maybe was jesus the carpenter and then
joseph was the joseph is who's joseph
mary's the mom jesus is the son
god is allegedly the father word up we
needed morey back in the day i'm married
to a catholic right you should know
better i am a total mess and i'm ashamed
you should shout out love catholics love
it all love it all um okay the book is
incredible it's so well written i
giggled so like actually laughed out
loud so many times it's incredibly well
written it's very funny while also
touching on some of the darker moments
in life i highly recommend it it's
available now it just came out mazel
tove thank you thank you for coming on
the toast thanks for keeking with us
talking about pop culture everyone pick
up a copy of happy people are annoying
by josh peck
oh no happy people are annoying yes not
happy people are the worst happy people
are annoying by josh peck josh thank you
for being here boobie love you thank you
love you everyone thank you so much for
a great week of episodes we'll see you
back on monday with uh jackie she's
joining us remotely and we have a great
week of co-host coming up
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcast anywhere
podcasting we found so it's spotify
institute public radio ir radio cast box
all the places where we listen to
podcast find us some morning tools leave
a five star view about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing weekend stay safe and
we'll see you on monday bye
you